we have had some questions in from some
of the fans some of the viewers of
computerphile
and we thought be nice idea to have a
chat and you don't you think so I've
picked a few that maybe hopefully will
go together and and we may well do some
others at another time we're gonna kick
off with this one here from Pasha Gorton
who I think you may actually yes fine
factory queue is one of my project
students a year or two ago yeah hi he's
that's four questions so we'll whip
through these before getting on to some
others so what is your favorite area of
computer science my favorite area of
computer science well it's it's it's
split into two really although it's very
very applied computer science I really
do like everything to do with digital
documents right through from the sort of
XML structural stuff right down to the
nitty gritty typesetting fonts and
PostScript stuff I love that but if you
were to say is there an area I like
doing videos on which fascinates me
although it's not really my specialist
area the answer is what we're doing at
the moment which is regular expressions
I think they're fascinating they're so
easy but so difficult you get regular
expression wars between commenters
they're wonderful there's a way to go
yet on our ease before we finally say
that's enough yeah well it's interesting
because you kind of roll these first two
questions together so we'd ask the favor
area to work in and that the area most
interesting what's the area of computer
science that your bath start you know
that's a very good question Patrick I
can tell you or one of my
students and I supervised how long your
knowing the answer truthfully is that I
don't consider myself an outstanding
computer scientist in any of the areas I
suppose you could say insofar as I have
some expertise the whole digital
documents electronic publishing
low-level PostScript PDF stuff yes but
actually what am I really best to us it
finally dawned on me and thanks to you
and Brady you have given me the ability
to exploit this I'm best at explaining
things to people and as I've often said
I when I was younger had to teach myself
the whole extra episode on why to be
competent in a wide range of things and
being forced to teach something is the
best way to learn it so I think I am
good at that the problem I had was if I
was like Brian Kernighan and had the
tenacity to write lots of books that
would have been a way to propagate my
expertise I don't really have the
patience to write books what I wanted
was somebody to come and just talk to me
and make videos from my waffle and you
and Brady honestly I remember that first
visit and it's been solidly downhill for
seven years ever since then hasn't it
2013 something like that yeah Patrick
also had a question which connects to a
couple of other questions going to roll
these together if that's all right with
you what is the area of computer science
that looks to be most important in the
near future which connects to one
Richard Denton's asked about your
extensive history in the new field of
computer science what direction is it
heading in and bragger who said which
area of CS will in the near future be
used the most and which do you think
there's no future - I'm not very good at
futurology I could list all of the
things which I've come across in
computing and have said that will never
catch on
but the six months later it's the lead
topic in the whole field now I think all
right let's just say recently the thing
this has quite taken my breath away has
been the whole stuff about neural Nets
deep AI and so on and now it's
fascinating because I think what is the
most fascinating thing you had deep blue
playing chess basically by brute force
messes and back in the 80s I don't play
chess by the way but I do find it
fascinating it was deep blue IBM's deep
blue I think that defeated Kasparov for
the first time you know and I felt well
it's just brute force and ignorance that
but on the other hand the moment you
start doing your own networks which you
learn and adapt and once you start
feeding in the fact that you can play
yourself in a computer memory of the
game you know what they've done on go
and chess and all that now is to say we
don't just hard code the rules and and
look searching moves ahead we'd get it
to find out what unlikely things have
come up in me playing myself where we
just went berserk and went off an attack
I thought that's a lost game but it
wasn't he found a back door way in and
triumph and I think that's what took the
gold guy was it he said all apart he
just thought that's ridiculous I'm gonna
win this one then about 20 minutes later
he hadn't and I think he found that
shattering that and I can well imagine
that and I think my understanding very
limited of this is that the deep mind
people have now started applying all
that they did to go apply it back to
chess and don't use brute force just
build up millions of games and let it
learn what's a good thing to do and I
think I'm right in saying that that
piece of software using the neural net
statistical whatever is now more
successful than the original D
blue was but I'm not sure so what you
can say is taming big data via AI is a
tremendous area it's it's I mean big
data is important and the degree to
which you can tame it with a so called
AI is fine but the big question still is
you go to the authors of these quotes
highly intelligent programs that they're
not and you say can it do common sense
no not hope it's brilliant that go
because it's still a narrow and
well-defined field but don't ask it to
pontificate on the state of politics in
the Western Hemisphere we have a clue so
there we are right something that I know
I'm interested in I know very little
about but does seem to me to be a real
marker for the future maybe onto a
different subject we had a question from
Eric Stearns and he said as engineers we
all have our pet projects while being
some of your hobby projects can be
related that you're most proud of and
would you tell us a bit about them all
right well I suppose I should say at the
start that one of the advantages I've
got being the ripe old age I am is that
I've been what's called an America
emeritus professor for well over ten
years now and that this does give me the
ability to pursue lunatic things that
would never ever remove got me promoted
to professor but I was there we tell
people what emeritus means for those who
don't know those around in academia what
happens with emeritus professors is that
it's basically a way of pension ah--you
off which in a gentle way the idea of an
emeritus professor the latin of course
means e out of marries because of merit
you have given this honorary position it
varies very much as to which university
are in as how active an emeritus you
want to be but for me i back in 2005 i
came off the regular pay
as a professor and cut a deal as it were
where I will be brought back on a
renewable yearly contract to do fill-in
teaching on stuff I lights but the good
thing is with no major administrative
responsibilities so I took my pension I
got some extra top-up from the school of
computer science and really I think the
last actual taught course I did
given that I formerly went emeritus in
2005 I was still teaching classes
through for 2013 and why did I change
tack then well once upon a time to her
suit guys came into my office and said
hello we're Brady and Sean we're going
to reshape your future you've wanted to
find somebody idiotic enough to record
your waffle
that's us well it's true isn't it I
always love the teaching but to be able
to teach in a way like this which would
never have got me promotion to anything
had I tried to do it as a 30 year old
you know which is why in many ways I'm
so glad that Steve and Mike are still
happy to do it because it can be part of
what you do but it can't be the totality
of what you do and yet for me now it
really is almost a totality of what I do
you've given me a Avenue spread the
gospel or something yeah so that's what
it means to be an emeritus professor
it's given me complete freedom to do for
example the stuff we did rescuing the
band paper about the Linotype 202
typesetter now it was such a good
project because it was Brian Kernighan
's work virtually computerphile
regularly now is although the virus has
confined him to the stage for the moment
but yes it was his work way back in the
later
which had been banned from publication a
mutual friend of both of us Chuck
Bigelow who's the designer type the code
designer of the lucida surfaces
basically said to both of us we know him
well he said you two you should be
telling the story now he's not sensitive
anymore so we did all those videos on it
but in order to get the story total I
said to Brian wait what we have to do is
not just resurrect this memo which was
on yellowing paper that have been
photocopied in 1978 we've got to
recreate it using modern PostScript PDF
fonts technology at the quality that was
innately there off the Virgin fresh
bromide that came out of the 202 and
it's got to be really good and Postgres
up to the job you know that is the the
glue that binds it all together we can
we can do it but I wanted it to be a
perfect resuscitation as it were and
getting that last few percent right was
just very rewarding but very frustrating
I mean we had it published it's had very
good reception people loved it when when
they find it but could I seriously had a
beam on the end of the yearly review
have to say this caper that we did does
that count towards making me a professor
by I think my previous heads of
department know it's frivolous it's
interesting because that kind of leaves
on too many other questions which is
from Jonathan lies Strom I hope I'm
saying that right ask professor
Brailsford how he learned to be so
pedagogic well-versed and an absolute
joy to listen to that's going to be nice
to hear I assume I'm saying pedagogic
right I think you are well thank you for
the implied flattery is it Jonathan
thank you the thing is of course that my
style doesn't appeal to everybody well
some people find it too awfully to hand
wavey and although I love explaining
things to people I just love it when I
get real experts come at me just the odd
one and it's always David if you did a
good job but you were on thin ice you
very nearly started telling things it
was all flatly untrue and I thought I
thought this is it is gonna fall down
into the ice bit we're now on you at the
last minute oh you know you rescued
yourself you didn't tell an untruth but
it's not the way to explain it to which
my retort is if I get people saying I
didn't remotely understand it till I
explained it my way then I rest my case
I was new I enjoyed teaching but the
answer is very simple when we were
turning from a computer science group in
a maths Department this was in 1986 to
being a full-fledged computer science
departments eventually it didn't dawn on
me because I was leading the charge on
this that we'd actually have to teach
across the whole range of computer
science so we took a first few single
long as computer science students in
1986 and then they simply hit me over by
1989 we've got to give them a full-blown
computer science experience and how many
people do I have six that includes one
technician oh my lord how are we gonna
do this and I said to people I remember
one of the first departmental meetings I
remember saying look we are very very
short staffed I think that University
will help us out with one or two but it
won't be as many as we need sorry folks
we've all got to be prepared to teach
well outside our comfort zone and that
is the answer to the real question is
why can you teach over such a broad
range I had to I had to learn about
Chomsky regular expressions Turing
machines and all that because at the
time I didn't have specialists to teach
it
comes back to the main thing I enjoy
teaching difficult things just by saying
I found it difficult here's how I got to
grips with it and if that style of
explanation suits you then it's a
win-win situation
so we've had it question from a very
familiar name here Graham Hudson have
you heard of this character well yes
you know Riggs about if you could have
invented one idea in computing what
would it be again first obvious answer
is would have been invention or what is
to be discovery was it in some sense
there already I have often thought about
this but the the stuff I would love to
have been more involved in I would love
to have been at the right place to be
heavily involved in it in the late early
60s to late 70s it was over a long span
is the whole area of Chomsky types three
and two which covers really regular
expressions when do they run out of
steam what theorems can you prove about
them now it's it's an area that we're
still coming back at but the one person
sorry to be boring everybody venerates
him for different reasons still with us
and I reserve the right to come back and
do a biography of him in some sense from
my knowledge of it ken Thompson I mean
there was regular expressions invented
by Stephen cleaner and yes they were
fine but not a lot of people understood
them and one of the people who really
understood them was not a sort of avowed
a declared theoretician but Ken Thompson
is the world's ultimate super duper
computer programming practitioner he
just understood in a very very deep way
what a nice regular expression could do
and couldn't do and more to the point
there was a very important theoretical
paper
by Dana Scott Michael Robin which
basically said these regular expressions
give rise to automata diagrams which
we've done but of course a lot of these
automata diagrams basically say well
what's the next character in your input
stream letter a oh I can go in three
possible directions on an a which one do
you want me to tell you and the trouble
is if you guess wrong you end up down a
blind alley and you have to backtrack
out and you have to redo and put back
again every variable you set in trying
to analyze it you've got a reset and
that's massively expensive you say so
what Scott and Robin did was to prove
that everything that was
non-deterministic could buy a
algorithmic process be turned into
deterministic except it might have a lot
of extra states and it might have a lot
of extra escape chutes labeled empty
that took you down to a false ending and
you had to build a Cobra can kind of
instinctively understood that you know
the the idea that you could make it
deterministic this is what Lex does for
those of you who are into using UNIX
tools and I was just appalled and amazed
that that was possible I thought I'd
love to have done that but I would have
loved to have had Ken's sure-footedness
in his favorite servitude QED
he built in the whole deterministic
non-deterministic thing in ordinary UNIX
edie he decided that the labor involved
wasn't worth the candle you know and he
quite happily and what better programmer
to do it said at times although
recursive backtrack is deprecated a
little bit of it so long as you don't do
too much I know how to do it
and he was just such a master programmer
he could make it work either way we
would say to town as a man goes sounded
to me 20 years going I first stumbled on
this very much like Yoda the Jedi
master for those of you coming into this
cold and direct because you saw the word
Yoder and grep over the entire universe